voilà donc pour l'instant on était
visiblement à la plaidoirie de l'avocat
vous l'avez vu beaucoup d'image arrêté
comme on dit dans notre jargon cela
signifie que pour le procès a été
augmenté et commandites beaucoup
d'imagés arrêté sans doute pour ne
pas montrer les membres du tribunal qui
ont condamné les faits exécuté somme
c'est ce que je propose maintenant comme
ce procès la diffusion du moins
commencé il ya une vingtaine de minutes
de prendre toute connaissance de il
prend la parole ce procès avec
elizabeth the teenagers
le tribunal militaire est hors-champ les
huit caméras filment les deux facultés
nicolas et les l'accès aux pièces
courtes
ses meilleures joueuses
l'homme qui fait office de procureur les
accuse de graves crimes dita von teese
incompatibles avec la dignité humaine
et demande la condamnation à mort
cet acte d'accusation c'est ce que dit
qu'ils refusent de répondre ailleurs
que devant l'assemblée nationale c'est
un rythme qui est pour lui demande qui
est responsable de la situation
désastreuse du pays qui a donné
l'ordre de tirer à timisoara qui a fait
tirer sur la foule
place du palais à bucarest ce jeudi 9
cents qu'ils aient à payer des
mercenaires étrangers qui se battent
contre les romains
nicolas hayek s'est historiquement
je ne répondrai à aucune question sauf
devant l'assemblée nationale et les
représentants de la classe ouvrière
que le momentum pitié devant ce coup
d'état je ne répondrai pas